alors vous serez sûrement d'accord avec
moi pleurait comme le lien le plus fort
entre deux êtres c'est le lien amoureux
on est d'accord et c'est vrai qu'au
début de la relation cela a tellement
fort qu'on a la prison bien d'autres
existent on est 70 nuage tout va bien la
vie est belle le monde peut s'écrouler
on est là tous les deux c'est
merveilleux vous au nez bon
malheureusement au bout de quelques mois
de quelques années effectivement le lien
peut se détendre un petit peu mesdames
vous allez chez le coiffeur et puis il
faut une semaine pour remarquer vous
avez changé la couleur de vos cheveux
messieurs vous avez tadini la semaine
dernière et pendant une demi heure elle
a rigolé avec tout le monde en disant
que vous étiez incapable de changer les
couches de bébé
alors effectivement tout le monde a bien
ri sauf vous et puis moi au bout de
quelques années comme ça les petites
incompréhensions du quotidien arrive aux
six mois pour moi au début de mon
mariage c'était quand ce qui m'agace
c'est un petit peu ce que je comprenais
pas tout à fait
c'est comme un femme corinne se lever le
matin elle allait vers sa garde-robe
elle ouvrait sa garde-robe il me disait
j en ai m g vous à cirer moi chaque fois
je me disais mais pourquoi le moment ah
oui ça garde vraie plaie ya plein de
vêtements partout et pas que dans sa
garde-robe en plus jeunes à la cave au
grenier en haut en bas y en a partout
donc je démens femme regarde ta garde
aurait plein mais et même si j'irai
médias m oui bon c'est pas très grave on
ne peut pas séparer pour ça c'est pas
dramatique mais quand même des petites
incompréhensions qui détendent un petit
peu de ce lien moi je pensais que
c'était normal en fait on disait aussi
un peu tous les couples au bout de
quelques années on sait tous que c'est
comme ça c'est la vie
on dit toujours que l'amour dure que
trois ans donc j'étais un peu sur cette
cette idée qu il fallait qu'on vive avec
ça c'était pas très grave non plus et
puis il ya un peu plus de vingt ans on
était marié depuis deux ans deux ans et
demi j'ai assisté à une conférence de
john gray un peu par hasard aux états
unis john gray venait d'écrire son
fameux livre les hommes viennent de mars
les femmes de vénus on a parlé de mars
et vénus tout à l'heure on va en parler
autrement maintenant ici c'est juste
pour l'image mais
j'étais un peu sceptique au début par
rapport à ça parce que je me disais que
c'était sûrement pour tous ces
américains que j'ai divorcé quatre fois
ça va pas correspondre notre culture
européenne et puis toute façon moi j'ai
aucun progrès corrie devrait on s'entend
bien quand même encore en deux ans on
n'a pas eu trop trop de temps non plus
avoir trop de problèmes mais en fait
quand j'étais aussi trouvé que c'était
un peu de pâte et rip le métier jean
andeka c'était un peu seriez comme ça
mais des gens les hommes les femmes on
est tous quand même différent on est on
est chacun unique et dont j'étais un peu
sceptique mais j'ai quand même et
écouter ce qu'il avait à dire est
vraiment quand j'ai entendu john gray
j'ai adoré ce que j'ai entendu parce que
j'ai vraiment eu des réponses très
concrètes par rapport à plein de ce et
toutes ces petites interrogations du
quotidien mais par exemple j'ai compris
que quand où j'ai compris qu'il y avait
bien logique différente j'ai vraiment
appris à respecter cette logique
féminine j'ai appris cette logique
féminine je serai donc c'était vraiment
de langage avec le masculin féminin et
un notamment par exemple j'ai compris
quand encore il me disait j'ai rien à
mettre ce qu'elle disait en fait
messieurs il faut savoir qu'une femme
que sa vie en fonction de l'humeur dans
laquelle elle est donc quand elle déjà 1
à mettre ce qu'elle dit réellement sais
j'ai pas de vêtements qui correspondent
à l'humeur dans laquelle joue ici ce
matin
hélas beaucoup d'humeur alors que moi je
l'entendais comme j'ai pas de vêtements
ya pas de vêtements dans ma garde-robe
ce qui était tout à fait faux et donc
voyons on est vraiment cessé toute
logique ces deux langages différents
j'ai adoré ce que j'ai entendu j'ai
commencé en parle autour de moi et j'ai
créé des ateliers de communication sur
ce thème et puis il ya quelques années
j'en ai fait un one man show est en fait
c'est ce qui me passionne vraiment
partager ce tous ces thèmes autour de
moi vient tout simplement de mon
histoire personnelle
il faut passagers que mon père est un
papier dans son domaine après course à
petit a quitté ma mère à ma naissance
pour partir avec sa secrétaire
bon c'est un grand classique aujourd'hui
mais à l'époque ça se faisait pas encore
trop il ya peu plus 50 ans était un des
premiers à le faire mais est ce qu est
un peu plus singulier dans mon histoire
c'est que jusqu'à l'âge de 13 ans j'ai
cru que mes parents étaient encore
ensemble parce que ma mère m'avait juste
dit papa travaille trop loin on ne peut
pas rentrer tous les soirs à la maison
et ce qui est assez marrant en plus
c'est que j'ai trois grandes soeurs de
mes deux soeurs étaient au courant de la
vérité parce qu'elle c'était difficile
de le cacher les avait 8 8 et 10 ans
mais ce qui est incroyable c'est qu'il
ne nous en ont jamais parlé et quand je
vois aujourd'hui taurine et moi on a
quatre enfants aussi
mais quand je vois mes enfants interagir
entre eux maintenant je peux pas
imaginer que des choses pareilles ne
puisse pas être dit entre enfants même
si des parents veulent le cachet pour
les meilleures raisons du monde mais
comment est ce qu'on a pu vivre pendant
des années sous le même toit en tant que
frères et soeurs sans en parler c'est un
peu les secrets secrets de famille mais
tout ça pour vous dire que j'ai été
élevé dans un environnement la
communication n'est peut-être pas totale
l'idéal par rapport à certains points
importants et je pense que là la passion
que j'ai développée par rapport à ce
derby a tout simplement du fait que
j'aime dit b si ça peut aider des
adultes à être dans un environnement un
peu plus vrai être un peu plus vrai en
tre cèdera seulement les enfants qui vit
dans cet environnement là être dans un
environnement un peu plus vrai un peu
plus serein peut-être un peu plus serein
que celui dans lequel j'avais j'ai
grandi donc voilà pourquoi j'ai souhaité
me passionne maintenant depuis des
dizaines d années on va parler ce soir
un peu de d'une erreur à mon sens ce qui
est fondamental dans cette relation
entre les hommes et les femmes qui
créent beaucoup des gars qui crée
vraiment que ce lien se détendent petit
à petit et je veux parler de celle
erreurs que l'on va faire c'est qu'on
fait on va donner à l'autre ce qu'on
aimerait bien recevoir
or en fait mais ferme on ne se sent pas
du tout aimé pour les mêmes raisons et
pour mettre en perspective ce que j'ai
parlé à partager avec vous avant de
comprendre tout ça dont je parte en
dépassement en déplacement professionnel
car ils me posaient souvent plein de
petites questions sur mon voyage très
gentiment et de manière très très
avenante tia keller est ton avion avec
love que d'arriver à l'aéroport est ce
que t as et en correspondance ou et
plein de petites questions très gentils
comme ça chaque fois qu'elle me poser
toutes ces questions malgré tout mon
sentiment c'est est au mieux de la
différence mais c'était plutôt de
l'agacement parce que je me disais je me
sentais moins attaqué dans ma compétence
très forte masculine être capable
d'organiser des voyages tout seul donc
j'avais pas trop et moi comment je
faisais moi tout simplement j'y vais
avoir mon amour à lundi à mardi juste
que tout va bien très bien se passer et
plus tard il m'a dit aussi mais tu sais
quand tu perds tu fais comme ça moi
aussi mon sentiment c'est est au mieux
la différence mais plutôt de l'agacement
aussi parce qu'elle elle se disait mais
c'est facile pour lui il paraît puis
metz les enfants son chien oui j'ai eu
un saint-bernard un peu avant de
rencontrer la vad opté quant à lait des
vaches et c'est encore mon chien les
enfants mon boulot il paraît puis s'en
fout donc et 900 cas pas non plus du
tout d'amour donc dans ce truc idiot du
quotidien et en fait sans nous en rendre
compte
on faisait les raids de donner ce qu'on
aimerait bien recevoir
parce qu'en fait aux mêmes femmes on ne
se sent pas aimer pour les mêmes raisons
pour se sentir aimé un homme a avant
tout besoin de ressentir de la confiance
alors qu'une femme elle a avant tout
besoin de recevoir des attentions en
fait corinne à travers toutes les
petites questions qu'elle se posait
c'était plein de petites attentions
plane manière de montrer tout l'amour
qu'elle a pour moi et moi qu'est ce que
je faisais jude est la meilleure preuve
d'amour que je connaissais je faisait
totalement confiance qu'elles étaient
suffisamment grande dynamique organisé
débrouillarde
mais le problème de ça c'est que corinne
peut mener des couches et des thoniers
de me faire des tonnes et des tonnes
d'attention je m'en fous enfin je les
prends un c'est pas désagréable mais
c'est pas ça qui réellement motivant
pour moi dans la nation et moi je peux
lui faire confiance confiance confiance
s'en fout complètement aussi et c'est là
on va sortir tous les deux épuisé en
ayant l'impression d'avoir est
extraordinaire en merlot d'avoir fait
plein d'efforts pour l'autre et devient
avoir reçu en retour et c'est comme ça
petit à petit qu'on disait qu'on est les
seuls à faire tous les efforts dans le
couple et claude de fous rires et petit
à petit le lien se détend se détend un
petit peu maintenant que j'ai compris ça
maintenant qu'on a compris tous les deux
ça j'aime coric donc ça me pose aucune
aucun problème de lui montrer que je
laime donc j'ai compris maintenant que
c'est à travers les attentions
et donc maintenant quand je pars barre
avant de partir je bosse pas une
question mais sincèrement un seul truc
volet s'insérer dans le fait je crois
que la question comment ça va se passer
tout ça est donc à travers toutes les
petites questions que je pose mes
l'heureuse toutes les petites attentions
il ressent tout l'amour que j'ai pour
elle et moi maintenant belle ne me pose
plus de questions sur mon voyage
et si jamais un jour j'attends d'avion
je téléphone et lui dit simplement
qu'elle aurait tant prochain vol eva
plus commencé à me dire ah tu vois je te
l'avais bien dit heureux de prendre
l'avion plutôt plus tard gignac et le
fait que je n'ai aucun tous ses petits
commentaires c'est comme ça que je
ressens tout l'amour qu'elle a pour moi
à travers la confiance qu'il me fait en
fait homme et femme
on a besoin de deux ingrédients chacun
pour se sentir aimé côté masculin il a
besoin de confiance et d'appréciation le
côté féminin lui il a besoin d'attention
et de compréhension
ce sont quatre mois inscrire en lettres
d'or quelque part ce sont vraiment les
mots qui vous qui crée le lien qui crée
vraiment ce lien amoureux qui permet de
brécé dans ce cercle vertueux où
donne à l'autre ce dont il ou elle a
besoin alors je vais en parler
brièvement de ces deux c4 de ces quatre
points le premier scellé ce sont les
attentions
et pour ça on pourrait comparer une
femme un jardin pour coiffer pourquoi un
jardin parce que qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire pour qu'un jardin ça beau
l'entretien est l'art osé enlever les
mauvaises herbes le labour et tout ça au
nom non non non pas ce soir on était
encore dit ce qu'il faut faire ça tous
les soirs tous les jours ouais pas que
la bourre et avant tout à coup sûr
entraîné au jardin est-ce que ce que dit
un jour jamais et bien pour qu'une
relation fonctionne bien une femme a
besoin d'avoir des preuves quotidienne
quelle est la relation la plus
importante dans votre vie messieurs et
ça ce n'est jamais acquis une fois pour
toutes
or qu'est ce qui se passe au début de la
relation mais l'homme c'est le prince
charmant grand beau et fort qui veut
vous montrer comme il est amoureux de
vous est donc naturellement il multiplie
toutes les petites attentions début vous
souvenez mesdames il vous la portière il
offre un bouquet de fleurs il y des lay
est présent et tout ça donc c'est mignon
sous le jardin fleuri c'est mignon c'est
gentil tout ce qu'on veut et qu'à un
moment donné un engagement est pris
d'une manière ou d'une autre
hélas ce moment là l'homme se dit ok
objectif atteint c'est pour ça que je
laime affaire classée et comme un autre
un homme attend dans un side
séquentielle lui ferme le dossier prince
charmant et louve le dossier sûrs au
travail pour instruire quand vous fait
danser la famille et à ce moment là la
femme se dit mais c'est dingue ici je
viens d'engager mon jardinier et le
lendemain la signature du contrat il en
veut plus au bout de quelques années des
communes
une femme peut demander à son partenaire
est-ce que tu m'aimes encore déjà posé
la question mais m
généralement l homme répond bien
évidemment puisque je suis là et puis je
te les gays cinq ans que je t'aimais te
souviens tu vas quand même pas mal
demander tous les jours
un jour un homme me dit ah tiens
comprend maintenant pourquoi même femme
est un peu frustré parce que chaque fois
qu'elle me demandait ce que tu m'aimes
lui répond tu seras la première personne
informée qu'en ce ne sera plus le cas
pas terrible comme réponse
messieurs elle ne le sera jamais une
fois pour toutes
parce qu'aussi bon ok tu pu être un
jardin dès qu'on arrête de s'en occuper
les mauvaises herbes se met à pousser
une autre petite attention importante à
avoir c'est tout et c'est tous les
petits gestes du quotidien ces petites
attentions et c'est jamais fini par
exemple messieurs quand vous rentrez
chez vous le soir chercher et prenez
votre femme dans vos bras avant de faire
quoi que ce soit d'autre
- avant ma logique c'était la suivante
moi je rentrais j'allais voir mon
courrier mais petit truc et je gardais
le meilleur pour la fin
débarrassé de tous ses détails je disais
bonjour à corinne jaurès et grid elle ne
percevait pas du tout comme ça elle elle
se disait je passe après son courrier
tous ces petits trucs et comment est-ce
qu'une phare à savoir quelle est la plus
importante dans votre vie et messieurs
mais parce que vous avez d'abord vers
elle un jour une femme me dit un brin
truc qui m'énerve c'est que chaque soir
quand mon mari rentre il dit d'abord
bonjour aux chiens et elle marie quitte
à côté lui répondais oui il court plus
vite que toi et si tu veux te disent
bonjour d'abord tac a enfermé les chiens
ont entraîné un peu moi je dis bonjour
dans l'heure d'arrivée de ce qui me
vient un monsieur s'est pas vraiment
qu'une femme à se cacher
ap allé jusqu'à se cacher mais elle peut
très bien ne pas tout à fait se montrer
pour voir si vous allez aller vers elle
c'est subtil zain oui ce n'est pas parce
qu'elle ne vient pas vers vous qu'il ne
faut pas aller vers elle
très important c'est comme ça qu'elle
voit si vous êtes attentifs ou alors
deuxième point très important pour elle
pour se sentir aimé c'est la
compréhension et pour ça on pourrait la
comparer à une vague parce qu'une vague
ya des hauts et des bas dans les eaux
comment ça marche
la vie est belle je t'aime c'est
merveilleux qu'est ce qu'on est bien
ensemble et oui je vais le faire il n'y
a pas de problème tout va bien c'est
merveilleux et puis à un moment donné et
dans l'esprit masculin sans aucune
raison particulière tout d'un coup il
n'y a plus rien qui va et comment est-ce
qu'on va remarquer ce changement de cap
ce changement du
heures est ce à ce moment là qu'une
femme a commencé à parler de plein de
problèmes et qu'il va utiliser ce qu'un
homme propre des exagérations
elle va utiliser des mots comme toujours
jamais personne tout le monde c'est
toujours la même chose tu ne fais jamais
rien c'est moi qui fais tout persane
samira j'ai eu aussi un oui est là
l'erreur que vont faire la plupart des
hommes à ce moment là c'est quoi ils
vont tout mettre en oeuvre pour couper
la vague
comment est-ce que le couple avec les
hommes il ya quatre étapes dans la
stratégie masculine pour couper une
vague vous allez voir c'est extrêmement
codifié première étape il arrive
gentiment avec la solution aux problèmes
aux gens neymar mon boulot je suis
débordé mais t'as qu'à leur dire que tu
peux pas tout faire
terminez solution au problème on perd
car ici on peut passer à autre chose
d'ailleurs bizarre qu'il y ait pas pensé
tout seul à cette magnifique solution
n'avait vraiment deuxième étape quand il
voit que ça marche pas ça les hommes
parce qu'elle continue à parler de ces
problèmes
ils vont alors utiliser des mots gentils
et rassurant du genre ça ira mieux
demain voit le côté positif des choses
c'est pas si grave que ça c'est dit sur
un ton un peu miel le un peu
condescendant sa salle nerfs deux fois
plus 1 messieurs 3e étape alors et au
bout de quelques années de vie commune
il va tout de suite à la 3e étape 1 vous
embarrassent plus les 2 premières en
tout c'est à la troisième on prend des
raccourcis il engueule ce cas ton
problème tu a tout pour être heureuse et
hull est pas encore qu'est ce qui te
[ __ ] plus dépressif cyclothymique
d'avoir un médecin va te faire soigner
et tout ça est la quatrième étape est
aussi au bout de quelques années il va
tout sud est le quatrième parfois il se
barre en lui disant mais si c'est pour
ma part aller comme un chien je préfère
aller faire un tour dehors et je verrai
quand on se sera calmée en fait
messieurs aucune de ces stratégies ne
fonctionne vous avez déjà tout essayé un
endroit on fait ça marche pas pourquoi
parce que l'erreur à éviter à tout prix
dans une relation il faut absolument pas
couper la vague lorsqu'il faut faire
c'est quoi
ce fait il faut l'accompagner dans la
descente
ce qu'il faut comprendre dans ces
moments là messieurs c'est qu'une femme
dépendante à côté rationnel à ce moment
là les dents ce côté féminin émotionnel
et que sa demande c'est juste de se
sentir compris dans ses émotions et
n'est pas en train de vous demander des
solutions
elle a juste besoin d'empathie d'une
écoute sincère et de nouveau il faut
faire ça sincèrement c'est pas évident
parce qu'effectivement il ya des hommes
qui ont bien compris un moment donné
qu'il valait mieux qu'ils se taisent
dans ces moments là parce que toute
façon tu toi qui dit ça va être retenue
contre eux mais le problème c'est que
elle commence à parler il faut pas deux
minutes pour qu'il tombe sur les
commandes de l'année de la télé où il
prend un magazine choses comme ça et là
j'ai vraiment la femme dit mais tu ne
m'écoutes pas à lui des hommes qui ont
un certain entraînement par rapport à
ses débuts ma chérie il répète la
dernière phrase par bons messieurs ça
marche pas ça dont elle a besoin que
vous soyez à 100% avec elle dans cette
écoute pour vraiment l'aider à
accompagner accompagner cette vague et
qc après la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'une
fois qu'il touche le fond il ya plus
qu'une solution
elle remonte donc c'est ce cycle est là
alors à votre ami yves médam quels sont
pour vous les meilleures chances de
recevoir les attentions à la
compréhension dans votre couple
mais c'est tout simplement de lui donner
la confiance et l'appréciation la
confiance pour un homme c'est quoi
mesdames on a vraiment ce qui est très
important pour nous c'est de nous sentir
cette confiance que vous ne donnez de
notre compétence à faire les choses les
femmes ne se rendent pas compte parfois
à quel point elles peuvent laisser un
homme par rapport à toute une série d
petite remarque qu'elles peuvent faire
qui sont juste des petites remarques en
l'air comme ça qu'ils n'en ont l'air de
rien mais qui peuvent être extrêmement
blessantes pour un homme et sa sagesse
innée chez dans les détails les plus
infimes du quotidien par exemple vous
emmène au restaurant pour la saint
valentin ou votre anniversaire son
espace payant papote on discute et tout
ça et puis au bout de quelques minutes
la femme d'avoir un jour un moment donné
elle va voir un tableau qui est accroché
au mur la lui dire ouais t'as vu le
tableau qu'est-ce qu'il est moche et la
lhomme arrête de parler pour le reste de
la soirée et la fin pour prendre
seulement parce qu'il s'est passé
mesdames
si vous emmène dans ce restaurant là
c'est que c'est lui qui a pas le tableau
c'est lui qui a fait toute la décoration
d'intérieur ils elles peuvent qui est
dans la setil et tout et tout remarque
qu'elle fait par rapport à leurs droits
de l'homme elle risque de le prendre
personnellement et la réaction masculine
à ce moment là c'est de dire mais si
c'est comme ça
la prochaine fois tu choisiras les
restaurants tout seul tu ira tout seul
restaurant est encore plus simple
pourquoi les hommes arrêtés attention
pour deux raisons la première
effectivement il pense que c'est plus
utile parce qu'on s'aime mais la
deuxième raison plus profonde c'est
parce qu'ils ont tellement peur de se
prendre deux claques dans la figure si
jamais c'est pas exactement comme vous
voulez mais dame qui n'auront plus rien
faire du tout le nombre d'hommes j'ai
déjà entendu ils ont l'entrée nettoyer
les vies de chez eux
il ne fallait pas des rires non c'est
pas dans ce sens là qu'il faut les
nettoyer
c'est dans ce sens là qu'il fallait être
hier à table et le petit coin là elle va
pouvoir tout ce qu'il a fait juste ce
qu'il n'a pas fait mesdames totalement
démotivant pour un homme vous allez le
payer d'une manière ou d'une autre
elham a aussi besoin enfin
d'appréciation parce que par une femme
tout comme un jardin au nord un homme
lui fonctionne comme un dauphin
vous savez comment dresser de phares et
les parcs aquatiques pour qu'il saute
dans les cerceaux sait comment fait on
toque du poisson le ton char a sauté
pour montrer comme les grands comme il
est fort mais aussi parce que chaque
fois qu'il saute il a du poisson à un
homme c'est exactement la même chose il
va être ravie mesdames de faire tout ce
que vous voulez à partir du moment où
quand il fait il là du poisson ils
passeront sais quoi mais c'est tous les
petits modules quotidienne vous pouvez
nous dire tous ces petits mots gentils
c'est petit compliment
merci beaucoup moins simple c'est très
gentil au d'efforts tu me rend heureuse
tous ces petits mots là mesdames on en a
jamais assez parce qu'autant un jardin
n'est jamais entretenu une fois pour
tout autant à dauphin lui n'est jamais
rassasié et mesdames on a besoin que ce
point sont là même si c'est normal qu'on
le fasse
tu as pourtant ce que vous de fabre et
this way jusqu'à normal qu'il le fasse
même si c'est normal en a besoin du
poisson il ya des femmes qui résistent
aussi parce qu'elle dise oui mais moi
aussi je viens moi pour agir a précisé
la fois par mois suivi de la vaisselle
quand c'est moi qu'ils vident les
valeurs au jour du mois
j'ai taux de réponse à sa ville m la
première c'est si vous en avez marre de
le faire 29 jours par mois
commencez par apprécier la fois par mois
il le fait ça va lui donner envie d'en
faire davantage plutôt que de le punir
j'ai appris qu'il ne le fait pas et la
deuxième réponse à ça c'est que mesdames
vous avez moins besoins d'impression
qu'un homme et c'est pas parce que vous
n'en avait pas vraiment besoin que nous
on n'en a pas vraiment besoin
petit exemple je suis à la maison en
train de passer l'aspirateur à l'étoile
du chêne j'en ai marre ce chien ses
poils peuvent que ring à côté de moi
plein de poissons comme mon amour c'est
extraordinaire ce tapis est nickel on
peut manger par terre il ya personne qui
n'était tapi comme toi ouais je suis
fort j'aspire deux fois plus fort le
tapis lesquels on peut manger par terre
l'inversé maintenant car il est en train
de passer l'aspirateur à l'épaule de son
chien j'en ai marre son chien j'ai un
côté d'elles mêmes choses plein poisson
quand mon amour c'est extraordinaire ce
tas qui dit qu'elles ont plongé partait
ya personne qui nettoie tapis comme quoi
je me prends l'aspirateur dans la figure
tu te fous de moi ou quoi c'est quoi le
problème est bien près l'appréciation
n'a aucune prise sur elle de quoi est ce
qu'elle a vraiment besoin d'attention
que je lui dise oh mon amour tu es
fatigué va t'asseoir je vais terminer
passer l'aspirateur d'accord mesdames
quand une femme à de la tension et de la
compréhension
le poisson c'est bien j'ai pas dire
qu'elle aime pas mais ça passe à qui est
réellement motivant pour elle dans la
relation mal inverse si corinne me
faisais cette attention là je suis en
train de passer l'aspirateur et elle me
dit oh mon amour tu es fatigué va
t'asseoir
et un problème je suis pas capable de
bill hader tu prends pour nous je n'ai
aucune envie qu'ils me fassent l
attention là on va fait l'erreur de
donner ce qu'on aimerait bien recevoir
les femmes vont donner plein d'attention
et de compréhension aux hommes voilà là
quand ils rentrent ils veulent pratiquer
jules préparer son petit dîner je ne
faisais pas une question il ya bien deux
pâles et bien je lui posais plein de
questions pour qu'ils parlent pour
qu'ils descendent sa vague il à mieux
sentir après c'est merveilleux et nous
les hommes qu'est ce qu'on s'en fout ta
nous devons le prendre c'est pas
désagréable mais c'est pas ça qui est
réellement motivant pour un homme dans
ses relations et les hommes qu'est ce
qu'ils font eux ils donnent plein de
confiance et d'appréciation ouais à moi
ma femme je lui fais toute confiance oui
à la manière dont elle gère les enfants
les écoles génial comme elle fait à j'ai
jamais vu à preuve de ma vie je sais pas
où ils ont magnifiquement vers les
vacances des six machines et donnons
c'est ton problème ainsi visité site
génial tu fais toute confiance et de
femmes en dire mais je m'en fous moi ta
confiance étant appréciation moi ce que
j'aimerais bien c'est qu'on aille voir
les profs ensemble que je me sente
soutenu qu'on puisse en parler mais
hommes selon la maman ma chérie c'est
merveilleux comme tu fais way est plein
de poissons et c'est leur petit à petit
on sait puis sous les 2 parce qu'on est
dans ce cercle vicieux où on a
l'impression de faire tout pour l'autre
et de ne rien avoir en reçu en retour
quand on comprend ses besoins
émotionnels différent quand on sait ce
dont l'autre a besoin pour se sentir
aimé qu'on en compte on l'est mais qu'on
a envie de lui donner
on retrouve très vite un cercle vertueux
pour retrouver le plus beau lien qui
soit le lien amoureux
bonne soirée merci beaucoup